So, what have you got here?
So, we have quantum locking, the superconductor is locked in space.
And it stays wherever I put it.
You see this is quantum trapping.
That's amazing.
As long as it's cold,...
...the superconducting is frozen with liquid nitrogen.
Upside down.
Alright.
And it stays locked.
So the fact that it's superconducting is locking the magnetic field in three dimensions, right?
Yeah, exactly.
And that pivots...
Because this is symmetric, it can rotate without breaking the locking.
The locking doesn't break.
Alright.
So, it stays there on the x and y but it pivots on the...
...yeah, on the axis of the magnet.
You see if I can move it on the side, it will again pivot around the axis of the magnet...
...because it makes sure that the magnetic field inside of it stays the same.